un gesto de protesta que ya es mundial
desde esta eurodiputada sueca
incondicional e inmediato de toda la
violencia contra las mujeres y los
hombres en Irán hasta que Irán sea libre
nuestra Furia será más grande que la de
los opresores hasta que las mujeres
dirán sean libres yin yang estaremos con
ustedes
hasta allí women
ya está celebridades como la actriz
francesa Juliette binoche al ritmo de
bella Ciao
la solidaridad se representa a través
del corte de un mechón de pelo esto en
las protestas antigobernamentales más
grandes en décadas en irán con mujeres y
estudiantes como protagonistas
desafiando la represión e incluso
retirándose el jillab estas continúan
pero también contra manifestaciones
como esta Pro gubernamental enteran la
capital este miércoles
fue la excusa de nuestros enemigos para
destruir nuestra unidad Mientras todos
hemos vivido juntos con diferentes
creencias y nunca fue un problema
Estados Unidos e Israel son la raíz de
todos estos disturbios solo porque no
pueden luchar contra nosotros están
tratando de atacarnos creando problemas
internos el martes es el presidente Irán
y ebrahimrah y habló de Conspiración de
los enemigos y mientras las
organizaciones registran decenas de
fallecidos desde el inicio de las
protestas Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea estudian sanciones
[Aplausos]